Oh Doug Doug what's going on man I I
don't judge your gift basket versus
Stern's gift basket I'm just holding it
up that's a nice-looking pink or is that
a black guy no I had I have to write
hello I had to read eyes from vomiting I
had gotten sick it was like all the
blood vessels in my face burst he was
like I was [ __ ] that's some strong
vomit yeah that would have gone viral if
you if I filmed it I know I didn't think
of it I didn't realize it was that bad
so I look to the mirror after it's very
hard to do a vomit selfie so what's in
the gift basket well there's a dammit
yeah I mean it really makes it that's a
good basket we are this is the gift
basket I brought for myself okay
booze yeah Travel sighs I don't I don't
look at the stern [ __ ] there's some
sponsored Underpants in there I won't
need those until I'm vomiting like you
are they me undies that's a good pair of
undershorts no you know what I'll tell
you we're not on the air right we are on
the air do you have Underpants
sponsorship we had me undies and I've
tried done Mac Weldon if you want to
know I've done them for the chip yeah I
have I have a sponsorship but I am brand
loyal sure to Saks underpants are the
[ __ ] best Underpants
that's a cks you know what if I lose my
sponsorship well you know what then
[ __ ] sacks will step up and match the
sponsor shirt hat because they are the
[ __ ] best and the sponsor I have a
fine pair of briefs but they're the best
they have a ball pouch I hold your balls
like a little baby's hand your balls
can't fall down your leg they won't
stick to your leg it's like wearing
women's underwear Jimmy okay fair enough
I got in men's underwear I'm a hundred
percent with you oh I'm bored so there's
some like these having me undies that I
had they made your dick look bigger
they were just better underwear oh yeah
no no thanks it might take were they
better underwear or just aesthetically
there's no better both they were
comfortable because you were like it
because I don't know if that's what
makes for a lot of people I think it's a
great
selling point that they should
capitalize off of but I've never heard
anybody sound like these this is a
better pair of underwear cuz your dick
looks bigger well you get too little
they're the airline bottles yeah you
didn't bring these on the plane I don't
have you noticed this I'm taking full
credit for this everywhere that in the
in-flight announcements now they start
at least Delta they started saying it's
illegal to bring your own alcohol drink
your own alcohol on the plane really did
not hear that why is that how is that
illegal well kids the same way it's
illegal to drink on the street or have
an open container but they can sell it
they can sell it but you can't bring
your own beer into a bar but that's not
illegal well you might get a dick move
is it really what yeah you can't drink
your own alcohol in a bar this laws for
Christ's sakes we're a nation but a
little illegal issue to bring your own
booze into a bar I'd be at the bar no
probably beat it with that but promoting
this since anyone was listening that
this is your 1 quart bag for your liquid
many bottles you get shampoo with the
[ __ ] odo in the land right
you bring your travel mug here empty
through security then you fill it at
Burger King or the bar they'll put ice
and [ __ ] you up soda in there for free
then you put in your vodka and then you
have there in the bag emergencies or
Airborne's the packets they're like
basically vitamin C alka-seltzer perfect
mixer if you just have bubbler water oh
it's nice so it's [ __ ] it's a free
way to get loaded at the airport right
Hani's on the airport dollar how did you
get dr. drew to write your bugs book is
called this is Fame and you can get nod
face oh sorry this is nothing you can
get sign copies and of course Doug
Stanhope calm there are sunshine follow
me what do you need how did you get dr.
Drew to write your for I asked him did
he know you didn't like him I did one of
the most vicious bits I've ever done
about a human being as on him
professionally individually yes the most
graphic description of how he should be
killed
yeah
was a hit piece Doug was and then I got
a email from his producer after that
aired on Netflix that he wanted me on
his podcast and I'm like guys this is
I'm getting yeah I'm getting set up did
he want to win you over
sometimes that's people sense that what
he did he did exactly the [ __ ] smooth
job won me over heart and soul and then
I was talking to Kreischer one day how
did you win you oh it was it just
because like oh he's a good guy or did
you start believing in what he does
right away I said okay I'm not here for
no reason right goes well no I heard you
had a beef with me but I I never watched
it because I I don't have the stomach to
look up negative things about myself on
the internet I and I that got me I go I
don't either
I [ __ ] can't stand I can't read a
single bad word about me on the internet
I avoid it so immediately I'm like all
right this guy's could be a human be
sure and I stuck by my points but yeah
it was very friendly from there on in
and then he started arguing against
himself better than I was right like he
took all my points and made them better
and I like you're killing me here is it
a way when you meet somebody that you've
bashed and then like all of a sudden
they're actually okay and you're like
[ __ ] I bashed the idea of them alright
bachelor I didn't like and I met them
and they shook my hand like oh yeah like
the thing you did no [ __ ] way yeah I
got I get a lot of that in the book
where my first couple of CDs were before
the internet or you - yeah where you go
okay the 60 people I just played to when
I recorded this in 1999 and then people
at the next show of 60 people are going
to be the only ones that hear this and
now Doug Flutie could actually be
googling his [ __ ] and I'm ripping on
his [ __ ] autistic son I didn't know
that was gonna happen yeah you didn't
see coming point you just happen to be
using old bit about remember every NFL
elite quarter
I had a kid that was [ __ ] up boomer
esiason senator mark Ripon Jim Kelly it
Phil Simms are no remember remember the
boom wasn't in the Bekaa but I was
talking about the bit was about how I
would never want a kid just because I
mean these guys are in prime physical
condition and they're all [ __ ]
skipping out [ __ ] water heads my baby
go on
hi I'm Doug Flutie and this is my boy
wacky he was born without bones I was
about if they're in prime physical
condition which I've done to myself
right my kid and I couldn't be a
responsible enough parent if I were my
kid was born with a three-piece suit and
a full time job an ingrown head out
there but yeah there were two bits I had
a bit I did when Ricky Williams quit
football right in the beginning of
training camp because he had you know
the 19th time he'd gotten busted for
being high he's like [ __ ] it I quit and
everyone was pissed off and I had a
really good bit about that Pro Ricky
Williams anti Fathead [ __ ] sports
guys that lived vicariously through him
and 12 years later he found that bit or
someone sent him that bit from XM short
leg I did what they down at wiseacres
and he's like wow it was good he liked
it yeah he loved it and so I balanced
that with I'm glad he found Internet but
if I ever saw Doug Flutie in a bar did
he know did he know you said that you
don't know you know Flutie know you're
not sure if you know but it's possible
the fact that you'd never you don't
realize the repercussions or couldn't
have realized I guess called out by
Steve Martin but I [ __ ] I bashed him
in my second book I really smack from do
incluso cuz that was [ __ ] not what
either sellers role which by the way you
don't have the same escape that doug has
it being like oh I didn't know everybody
was gonna see that I just put it in mind
you know I was 2008 I knew but you know
again I was I was kind of a dick when I
wrote that it was a lot
place plug for the Flutie foundation I
was doing some of the Tonight Show on
time and he was on I was kind of talking
and he recognized my name and he's like
you said some very unkind things about
me in your book and I was immediately I
was a [ __ ] but I apologized for it I
kind of felt bad anyway that was the
other cool about it but I felt like it
that's the thing of yourself you have to
own it and you know what there's no
repercussions you just feel like a dick
but did I have to feel like a dick
I apologized for it because he was there
or was there something that made you
take back what you thought a little bit
of both I felt bad because he was there
but I also felt like I was too harsh on
him because I was pissed off about a lot
of other stuff and a couple people got
lumped into that book that I think in
hindsight didn't belong there so what do
you do then like when you're like oh dr.
Drew's is actually a cool guy like not
only are you like trashing dr. Drew in
this like bit that everybody knows now
but all your fans that are gonna be very
loyal to you and kind of follow the
words that you say are gonna be like
yeah dr. Drew's a piece of [ __ ] and you
got to be the guy who's like oh actually
he's not a good guy he's actually you
guys shouldn't say that yeah he's nice
put a lot of it in the book he's helped
out it was Kreischer that said that he
goes to dr. Drew a lot because crisis a
[ __ ] alcohol so yeah he cares more
cuz he has kids so he gets a swollen
part which side is your liver on dr.
drew just had like a mid belly fart
where intestine shouldn't be at all and
I know you really talked to dr. drew
like that cuz I had some questions and
yeah he's helped me on stuff not even
associated with me but other people I
wouldn't know how to he's done so much
for me and he's probably because he's a
[ __ ] narcissist and he likes to do
nice things for people who've [ __ ]
hated him and convinced them that they
were wrong you know
you know how you [ __ ] with someone on
you know innit they send you a hate mail
and you turn him around oh yeah yeah
that bit was your arms and he just like
[ __ ] what it what's the word there's a
word for that but you yeah you just say
oh I'm sorry I really never thought of
it like that I really should probably
look at my bits of more clearly before I
speak out of turn thanks for bringing
that to my
yes and they immediately go I'm sorry I
didn't mean yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ]
smoking [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah I've known stuff that one just
because my dad had diabetes I felt yes I
can't when are you coming to Harrisburg
turn around quick sometimes they won't
but once it's long if you're Pleasant
even if you don't agree with them a lot
man if you don't like you don't listen I
just thought well if you're just human
back okay 90% of people like alright
he's just a guy it's hard for them to
stay [ __ ] pissed off at you yeah my
favorite one is in that book I'll do it
off the air I'm not gonna make you
[ __ ] read it on the air but this is
just an email exchange from a very
caustic woman who is all caps upset
about a show and then my response and
then the US at the break I got hate mail
from somebody one time years ago vile
hate mail is a pig and bah-bah-bah was a
woman and then we wound up getting to
know each other through talking and then
we wanna you know it became sexual talk
and then we wound up we never [ __ ] but
she did we did hanging it together we've
one of the most bizarre interactions in
my life but it started with a negative
hateful email exchange was like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you too and then all of a sudden
just kind of evolved into something else
happens something actually wasn't yeah
yeah 93 94 I was opening for the Edgar
Winter group at a biker bar in Billings
Montana and a woman in the front rows of
bar front row through a beer bottle at
me it hit Carmen to pieces drum set who
is playing with Edgar Winter
this filthy [ __ ] dive bar and
afterwards I wound up mate though they
come over security comes and I start the
nananana hey hey goodbye cuz you're
gonna get thrown out and they just asked
her to not do it again everyone gets one
free shot I ended up making out with her
at the bar after the show even though I
had a date that drove me there a girl I
was banging from Bozeman and she get all
upset I go no you can understand it was
the fact that I could make out sure you
won yes i won she hated you and you
[ __ ] won sometimes you just have to
prove
[ __ ] absolutely how are you can I ask
how your no how are you bingo how are
you doing do you want to come on you
come sit by Sam all you want said that
you sit there we sit away from me oh
I'll give you the creeps if I'm right
next to you right hello how are you
doing I'm doing well better every day
you are better every day yeah what
exactly happened you you fell right um
had a seizure uh had a traumatic brain
injury and then went into a coma for
like a week right yeah you were in the
hospital for a month and you're
basically in a coma for a month coma for
a week I don't remember anything from my
coma oh yeah the brain injuries are a
[ __ ] was like brain swelling
well there was actually brain fluid that
was coming out fracture yeah staples so
when do you start like gaining memory
back is it like from before you had the
seizure you remember from there and then
there's just nothing and then basically
and then when does it start to like when
do you start to regain consciousness and
be like I don't know what has happened
over the last however long it's been
short-term still [ __ ] yeah really yeah
but back then it was short-term to the
minute we write it what happened when
Trump got elected it was two nights
before and three weeks later she was
cogent enough that we could tell her
Trump was president every day her voice
is still [ __ ] now it's Trump shower
Time magazine how scared were you when
that happened do you think she's gonna
die not sure about I I'm sure I was more
scared that she'd be a vegetable yeah
honestly yeah
death was possible but yeah you know it
was she's just gonna be
the Terri Schiavo [ __ ] tube in the
neck
doctor said that to you - right they
said me being a vegetable was yeah it
was in the cards yeah do you have to
start thinking like immediately like
what how do I do that
yeah what do you think you and that
happens like I gotta be is gonna take
care of her
cuz if she's a vegetable she doesn't
[ __ ] care right someone's gonna have
to wiper and you know feeder or injector
or whatever they do who do I get who
needs a job Paul I said you would have
to hire like a full-time nurse somebody
caretaker yeah so when you woke up they
told you what happened you were in the
hospital you just like shocked you're
surprised I have no memory oh you don't
I don't remember she doesn't have memory
of even the brain rehab past when she
was somewhat cognizant but still not
there I remember a few months after it
so do you remember like the the time
period when you had like no short-term
memory when you were getting total
Donald Trump was the president every day
like do you have any kind of memory of
like oh yeah I guess I was told that
every day or that it all up here I'm
sure the cell phone videos why she
remembers anything which is weird what I
always say my earliest memory of being a
kid is this but is that just what I
pictured when my parents told me the
story I just do I have an actual memory
or is it like a photo you saw that
you're gonna play saying or yeah but she
that's the thing you know bingo she's
[ __ ] Daffy and [ __ ] before this
that much range it's fairly close to
things feel back to normal almost yeah
except for her she's like I don't feel
like bingo anymore I don't remember who
that person used to be I used to be fun
and now I'm not and I'm like yeah you're
fine you're just imagining yourself is
not fun yeah must be hard when you when
you have an idea of what you used to be
like you know you're the same as you are
but you might think like I know I was a
lot more different but you mean the same
as I remember I don't remember
everything
about who I was I don't remember at all
like personality traits and later yeah
yeah yeah after you realize that you're
lucky like do you recognize the fact
that brain injuries are usually a
[ __ ] that they usually hate the
charity yes I got that that's if that's
that's that's [ __ ] up though of like
the idea that like you can't just be
right because you know that you were
before and you've got this thing that
like I don't remember how I was so I
don't know how I should be reacting
instead I'm just naturally reacting to
stuff that's tough and I don't remember
like what I liked as far as music goes I
don't remember all of that
yeah so it's that feels tragic to me
that's it so have you developed any new
likes or stuff that you didn't like
before now you do like and you don't
remember not liking it before I just
wouldn't know has she like sake dude hey
we have by the way we have Doug is here
with us to Leah and we have another
guest but we all booked him because we
thought you only had you till 10:30 they
told us Doug's only 10 to 10:30 and then
we're like okay well book this guy 10:30
and then they're like no no Doug Stan 11
dylan mcdermott he's an actor he was an
American harvester so he'll be in with
us that was great we would have had you
exclusively we didn't know you were here
okay I played third no no but we would I
like him but I we will give you last
time I was on there was an actor or act
yeah I guess they're both actors now I
just bring him in yeah but that's but
just that's why we didn't realize we had
just 11 o'clock they they give us
different times they go no Doug there's
other press saying some inappropriate
stuff what's that because service animal
you were on the air so your dog just
[ __ ] in the hallway or what happened
yeah
running around in here hope you guys
don't mind I know I think it's great
no it's for Maalik of how things are
here yeah I wish there were more right
more you just got me to buy the janitor
do you bring the dog everywhere yeah
he's emotional support so if you guys
need any that's great
who's emotional he's much more your girl
family okay yeah now what did you have
to do to get an emotional support you
have to go to the doctor and say what
about doctor and you can explain why you
would need one
people are very it's a very
controversial thing now these emotional
support dogs because there are people
who like think that you need to like
really like unless there's some kind of
medical ailment you're taking advantage
of the system if I but I'm like I don't
know if I could get away with bringing
my dog everywhere I bring my dog
everywhere you know I find that it
relaxes people well having the dog
around yeah you can go to your vet to do
it or you can go to Amazon and just buy
the vest which I've done they can't
question it right no they Delta
crackdown now you need more paperwork
because he brag dogs dogs were brought
service pigs on the [ __ ] surface
turkeys and [ __ ] so now can you still
bring your dogs is there a problem for
you know I'd never brought him on a
plane oh my dog I actually got a sighs
that was a large and it weren't what
wasn't big enough for my big fat dogs I
just wanted to bring him in safely once
to see this grocery store where I shop
just so they could see where I go and
come out with all these fantastic treats
for him yeah this is the [ __ ] Magic
Kingdom but they misbehave way what are
you plugging what does it does it don't
you on the plane and no problems it's a
private jet yeah private enough filled
with sycophants
did your dog ever [ __ ] up on the plane
No
serious then he [ __ ] up yeah that's why
I always wonder what if your dog you
starts blocking how embarrassing video
it is it is right what service dogs
though are supposed to be like if it's a
real service dog they're supposed to be
trained to not just sit on a plane and
bark at people right something right
yeah providing service although yeah
your most service I think every started
for the blind yeah most service dogs
I've seen like they like sit quietly in
a spot I kind of love that your service
dog is just kind of wandering the studio
checking everything out first a nose is
there a difference between service dog
and emotional support no no same thing
same thing yeah motional support is just
kind of like look I can't a service dog
to me is like four blind people or carry
[ __ ] or guide you into walking in front
of a bus but I think emotional support
is people just like to travel with their
dogs yeah yeah we all like a dog I mean
petting a dog never sucks it's the
greatest right not the greatest
no one's ever like this is awful but I
don't know if it's necessary for yeah
travel so the new show is LA to Vegas
right is this because I didn't realize
until I watched the first episode and I
didn't realize until the end credits
that it was Gary Sanchez producing it
which obviously did the campaign to you
know is that were they like you know he
was great in the campaign we want that
originally I was I did Saturday Night
Live i hosted with will years ago and
then they thought of me for stepbrothers
yes I was gonna do Step Brothers did the
the table read for it which wrong for to
play Will's brother right and so um but
then I couldn't do what I was doing a TV
show they wouldn't let me out so when
the campaign came along I was like hell
yeah this is perfect and then we got to
know each other and they got they knew
my brand of humor because no one ever
thought of me is funny before I live LA
to Vegas so it was perfect because when
I read captain Dave I know this was the
character for me yeah it's like so the
show the premise of the show is like
it's I guess they're the airline that
just goes from Las Vegas to Los Angeles
back and forth
MGM Airlines used to do this era line
there was I never flew them dice told me
about it was like this big first-class
airline i fluid yeah supposed to be
pretty nice thing to do you ever I don't
know if it still happens I haven't been
to Vegas for a while and I lived
enough I'd usually drive but do you
remember when you'd land in Vegas
everyone would clap that was every
airline every place yeah
really clapping yeah and leaving was the
exact opposite everyone's dejected and
broken for a while so I knew was doing a
joke about that why do people always
clap when the plane lands what do you do
boo if it crashes I thought of that
recently I'm like I guess it was obvious
which is at that point I guess that was
my joke I suppose just commenting when
you I've always wondered about like sure
actors I wasn't asking you whether it's
like Carrie Sanchez or it's like Ryan
Murphy the American Horror Story
franchise like when you do something and
you guys get along and everything is
going right and this person or this
group that's creating continues to
create projects and they might call you
for this one but they're not gonna call
you for that one right does every
project that comes out do you go like
well what the [ __ ] why wouldn't you have
called me I would have done that
absolutely or like every season of
American Horror Story be like why do you
do you have a nemesis where you go [ __ ]
it's gonna be either me or him for this
absolutely your doppelganger the under
stealer well funny enough he was on the
show he guest-starred on Ellie to Vegas
there's been 30 years of people
confusing us and him getting roles or me
getting Yaphet Kotto yes and so we
finally figured it out and it's been 30
years as Dermot Mulroney yeah that was
your you are unique term it yeah yeah
start a podcast does anyone know who
Dylan that's right Brendan SNL yeah the
two of us there was a game show know if
you ever saw wait so there is it I don't
know if you're [ __ ] with me Dylan
McDermott
st. Thomas sighs Bourne who's the who's
the Tom Sizemore guy I don't know I
don't know which one was on Celebrity
Rehab
there's two that are like pink Tom sighs
Tom Celebrity Rehab all right guessing
he dated Heidi Fleiss Tom Sizemore that
would have to be yeah but there's a guy
that's exactly like him anyway that's a
guy
yeah the Dermot Mulroney move was a
pretty smart thing for the show because
now I mean like it like everybody is
because a lot of people got obsessed
with that comparison that's right and
the fact that people couldn't place it
and so I guess that was just I'm
surprised that it took this long for a
show to figure out well what if we just
got these two on the road everybody's
gonna talk about everybody to ever if it
came out that he was [ __ ] raping and
molest well I mean they were saying if
there was something negative happening
you may get associated with his yeah
it'd be funny if one does something
negative the other one got in trouble
right awesome right hey that's it this
screenplay writes itself
I have a question for you does we talk
before you came in Doug hosted the man
show with Joe Rogan why did crawl and
Kimmel leave that gig they they gave up
the the rights for creative control
so the Comedy Central the production
company owned the product and then they
had better [ __ ] always just to move on
and they both wanted to go okay did they
[ __ ] with you and all you do you want to
be near there the production company
yeah they [ __ ] ruined it they did
okay yeah we were just the faces that
had to up at the [ __ ] horrible
material was not good material no no no
it's a piece of [ __ ] when you have to
promote a terrible piece of [ __ ] how
much does it wrench your heart because
I've had a couple of things that I was
contractually obligated to go out talk
about it yeah the man showgirls got wild
turn who was my hero and falsely say
this is a good product when I know it's
the worst thing you ever had to promote
and how oh boy I mean
I guess at the time you believe in
everything right now you know I knew the
man show is a piece of [ __ ] but I
thought it could get better you thought
it had some potential they just let us
do it we want it won't [ __ ] get row 2
seasons right
no they we did 1 season it was so bad
that they called half of it one season
so you go back and reshoot and try to
make it better and it was they called
that the second season so it was you
know two half seasons anyway back to
your answer all right gave you time to
think sure tell me one show that you
just didn't can you do that without
[ __ ] yourself over no I can't
the one your least enthusiastic about
enthusiast a the least enthusiastic
would be girls going wild yeah this is
the opposite one that you really had a
trepidation about that turned out to be
fantastic where you thought oh I don't
really want to promote this this might
suck and you were wrong you can do that
one
you know what originally I was I was
nervous about doing television back in
the 90s when you did television it was
like a sign that your movie career was
over right and and when I read the
script for the practice which was on for
eight seasons I got nervous because I
was like oh noes is sending the wrong
message and then when I started filming
it I was like you know the show is gonna
be good and it wasn't originally they
put it on Saturday night at 10 o'clock
which is a you know death slot so then
it worked out we're on Sundays and the
show took off so initially I was a
little nervous about that one you know
you know pretty rough upbringing growing
up when you get into Hollywood there's a
lot of diva behavior a lot of people
that feel like oh man you know just just
complaining right yeah did it make you
did the [ __ ] that you had to deal with
growing up did it make you easier did it
make the industry easier to take did it
give you less tolerance for people to
complain about like bullshitty stuff
yeah I suppose it did I mean the great I
always say the greatest thing that ever
happened to me was growing up poor
because I'm always grateful you know and
there's a lot of spoiled people in the
world generally not even in Hollywood
but you know Hollywood is this what are
you a focus on hang on Kathie Lee
what kind of rough upbringing just poor
yeah you know beaten it's common
knowledge and I know you're I don't know
your career I know your face your dreams
[Laughter]
are you Irish yeah I was telling all
right Wow all right that's that's to
every Aggie joke so your mom I I know
your mom was killed right we but today
ago but I'm getting to blast for Sam is
kind of I think alluding to it it's
obviously a very rough way to come up
was it was it something that was ruled
accidental and then declared a murder
there was some kind of a somebody I
guess not how am i trying to say that it
wasn't it was changed what they thought
happened yeah I mean I really want to
get into that now you know I'm just
talking about Ellie to Vegas but okay
yeah it was definitely rough and that's
not Tuesdays and that's not the death
slot hey speaking of death okay what
time I love it
I'm a [ __ ] fan of flying I'm an
airline freak but this is a current day
it's not like Mad Men era they had that
Pam kind of modern day but it's modern
day and the reason tell the reason we
asked you about it is it's on the sheet
and they talked about how it kind of led
you into getting into acting like you
know through circumstances beyond your
control then you want up living here and
then you want up just kind of morphing
into a kit so it might not have been
something that you gotten into had
nature just gone a different direction I
mean who knows why you know but I my my
stepmother events or who wrote The
Vagina Monologues she invented them she
was she in bed yeah oh no she she was
the one who really just said I should
get into acting and encouraged me so you
would hear her just saying that kind of
stuff out loud the houses started so you
know she was an artist
she she explained to me you know how it
all works and oh right you you you don't
yeah
moving on to other things when you do
American Horror Story because I loved I
mean I still have American history but I
love I mean the first season right he's
one of those things that's a project
that was like what dog was talking about
where it's like I don't never really
been anything quite like that on TV and
I felt like that was one of those things
that like it takes probably a good six
to eight episodes to get into it to even
realize what you're watching that's
right
were you how confident were you that was
gonna work when you got it or was it one
of those things where you were like
let's just try this and let's see what
happens you know it's a couple times in
my career the practice I knew American
Horror Story when I read these three
scripts and LA to Vegas all three of
them when I read them I knew that there
was something special about them but
what American Horror Story specifically
I was like I want to do this I mean I
call them amaze my agent right away and
said this is this is it we got to do
this and and I loved especially that
first season something about that I
don't know if it's because it's the
family unit or yeah how it all works but
I thought that was the best season not
because I'm in it just because I think
it's Jessica Lange was in it before you
took the gig had she been cast like you
know it's probably not gonna blow if
she's in it I mean you know she's great
yeah I think so I can't remember exactly
uh but I think she was yes you get is
that a show that you get all the scripts
in advance or do you get do you go is it
like normal telling one by one because
yeah cuz that had to be like you're like
what what's going on next you get I
don't know my daughter was dead right
that's what I mean like the whole time
you good as nothing you get to like
episode 8 episode 9 episode 1 is a
completely foreign concept like you
can't yeah it's not just cliffhangers
and what's gonna happen next week it's
like this is a different show than what
I signed on for
I'd episode 1 but not in a great way
but Ryan you know entire Morphy is a
genius and I just trusted him I knew he
was gonna take us to the right spot
right spot yeah I also felt like these
like an introduction to the whole
concept where it's like now because
people are so familiar with it you can
kind of dive into whatever kind of crazy
weird supernatural thing yeah but late
there was real it was really yeah I
thought so too and you know it's a
promoting LA to Vegas on Tuesdays at 9
o'clock on Fox and Doug is promoting
this is not Fame which is available now
and you can go to Doug Stanhope calm and
get a signed copy are you doing any
physical signings we're gonna be places
now no we tried that on the last book
now we only did LA well first of all
there's no bookstores I wanted to do it
in airports [ __ ] Hudson news cuz I
fly for fun I literally will fly just
around the world never leave airports
for fun and Hudson News has every
[ __ ] bookstore in every airport why
don't I do it your airplane tour of
Hudson news but the [ __ ] I do no one
wants to [ __ ] read that flies you
just love to fly I love it I love a good
airline like I love a good a good
business class if possible it's you
happy you know what an amazing about a
la to Vegas is one of the cast members
on the show is the guy who was in Fargo
who plays like the guy that never speaks
and he's got like this kind of comedic
butcher guy that never spits no mer yeah
yeah and he's really uh he's really he's
genius I would recommend checking out
the show you can watch the first episode
on Hulu that's how I watched it last
works now how do you learn anything
about the inside world of flight
attendants and the whole business that
you didn't know before you did the show
I do but they say I can't talk about
until the show is over
I asked them one time if there was a
code word they used
I'm like if there's a prop right is
there something that they will say over
the PA which lets you the flight
attendant know that we're about to go
down and we're in deep trouble and now
one woman told me no there's not oh man
but is there a code right no I had that
code word for this interview you
[Laughter]
radio to do long 4-minute Delta Airlines
for if you're flying first if it's an
odd number flight they go from the back
first front to give you your meal choice
yes even even numbers selfie oh oh you
know it's always gonna be [ __ ] nice
beef sandwich or you know of you know
asparagus pizza yeah you know you're
gonna so yeah you get you go ah middle
for cash boys yes anyway depending on
which way they the plane is going
sometimes they'll uh so I hope you
didn't have a good time don't okay good
cuz we've isolated a few pairs okay
funny sky in the world brain whatever
you want yeah she get him I try to take
them off the wagon awkward deaths no but
your last book was called digging up
mother it's how I put my mother to sleep
euthanized her and that's how it starts
so I like to start the conversation at
the darkest levels and then try to crawl
your way out of it but then Jim Norton
is featured in that book
you probably scan to just the parts that
are about your horse I did that's why I
want a digital copy so I can just put
[ __ ] yeah she was nice that's like my
first time meeting Doug we've talked
about this before is the Vail Comedy
Festival Doug and I were roommates and
we slid we slept in the same room and he
had all his possessions on his bed and I
just don't do that you still do that
put all your possessions on your bed oh
yeah I pack lighter down it was crazy
well I drove back I lived out of my car
back there right oh all of my [ __ ] was
in my car so it's easier to just
especially when you have a hotel room
instead of a rest area to bring it all
in and then you can rearrange it all
holmen's in trouble Jay Scott Jenna's
cancer I heard yeah yes he's got a
GoFundMe I don't know I would I'd plug
it if we could yeah I don't remember
where it is Jason Austin now I guess
funny comedian and
really naturally fun yeah hilarious guy
he went on drunk with this [ __ ] thing
over just going booth or Comedy
Competition he's throwing it out cuz
he's drunk really a good dude and
apparently cancer so no it sucks
yeah it does it stinks I guess I should
promote his GoFundMe I don't know where
they can go figure it out hey Scott home
in hom a and find him go ghulam yes that
money I haven't seen him in many years
are you big on causes at all I do get
involved any that stuff you know pretty
much I leave it up to my mom her or she
has a gene called v-day v-day org
and that's really helping women around
the world whose visa based on like
vagina for Vagina Monologues much yeah I
remember that yeah I that's been around
for a long time hasn't yes it has yeah
that's that's kind of amazing that it's
so doing so you may get a lot of [ __ ] to
when it first started people thought it
was vulgar they got a point of it yeah
absolutely and so she would do that she
came up with this concept with the
people she was asking that wouldn't do
it they were like I'm not getting
involved with that it's - I think people
initially were a little afraid of it and
I've sort of warmed up over now and now
it's nothing right in today's climb what
do you think about what's happening in
like in Hollywood and all this stuff
like you just as somebody who works all
the time and who knows a lot of these
people who interaction with them you
know like are you constantly on guard or
like yeah how does it affect you you
know I think there's a there's a natural
cleansing that's going on you know
people will behave badly for a very long
time and and I think it's about really
you know not to get too deep on this but
I think really it's about transformation
rather than being punitive because now
it's just about you know fire and get
rid of and you're gone and go away but I
think you know ultimately very no trial
yeah I think men you know we I think we
have to change and we are changing but
there's certainly a cleansing that's
going on right now and the fires know we
have definitely hide yeah it is scary I
mean every guy goes over there history
popularity does not change human
instinct right but it on the hard side
rapists will go [ __ ] yeah I shouldn't do
that but and cease Ansari will still get
a girl to blow him and the next day
she's gonna go I can't believe I blew it
and sees I'm sorry and she won't be in
the picture so there are big levels the
fact that that was lumped in with Harvey
Weinstein's they come on yeah
I thought Louis was lumped in with
[ __ ] Harvey Weinstein [ __ ] that's why
it kind of gets watered down a little
bit yeah I think everybody's trying to
figure out what it is
yeah there's there should be different
names for a yeah the thing is Louie can
come back and I guarantee he will come
through and I said he should have come
back the [ __ ] next night and I said
it on stage going
he'd outsell me tonight at his worst
[ __ ] divot point in his career he
could come out and do an hour strong
about just this and out sell me five
phones at higher prices don't you hate
when you're in a town like we have to
wrap up to what you're doing a gig
somewhere and you're like I'll great you
see across the street [ __ ] this one's
in an arena and you'll go no because
it's usually whoever's in the arena
they're not flipping a coin if I'm
playing in a [ __ ] hole [ __ ] Road
House Tavern and Jeff Dunham or whoever
is in an arena
no one's going stanhope or Donham
puppets or fist [ __ ] you know you're
right there is no flip of the coin
they've made the decision long before we
got there you're right